ce matin lille bouthillier se lance à la
poursuite d'un animal sauvage
pour plein coeur de longueuil
la bête qu'elle traque est une petite
espiègle elle chante à tue tête et se
dérobe regard
vous d'humour
algérois
on préfère rochard accueille
la biologiste a posé quelques pièges
dans le boisé du tremblay
j'ai un couple
[Musique]
la fenêtre faux-grillon il était plus
petite grenouille du québec elle
tiendrait sur une pièce de dollars dès
la fonte des neiges le mâle pousse la
note pour courtiser les femelles
son chant signale l'arrivée du printemps
comme la migration des bernage ou
l'éclosion des bourgeons
rôle à bord
[Musique]
donc sont capables de le gonfler plus
donc la paille
[Musique]
ou cours des prochains jours la
biologiste a passé une centaine d'heures
les pieds englués dans le bout de l'eau
jusqu'aux cuisses de jour comme de nuit
elle espère capturer 50 mal et 50
femelles le défi sera difficile à
relever surtout pour les femelles la
bonne formule secrète et champeaux
[Musique]
céline boutier cherche à capturer des
rainette faux grillon c'est parce que
l'espèce est au bord de l'extinction
dans ceux du québec
autrefois leur chorale assourdissante
résonnait du pont jacques cartier
jusqu'à granby
puis en l'espace de 50 60 ans avec la
transformation des pratiques agricoles
développement urbain mais on est rendu à
quelques petites populations fragmentés
dans le paysage
line bouthillier a mobilisé une petite
ermite scientifique prétend dernier pour
éviter que le champ des rainettes ne
s'éteignent jamais nos boisés
une équipe de l'université laval il venu
lui prêter main forte son pu estimer la
taille des populations restantes en
montérégie au titre
l'équipe ratissent les étangs du côté de
boucherville il n'y a pas de temps à
perdre car il faut capturer les
rainettes avant qu'il ne quitte les
étangs l'arrêt des fauves lions ce qui
est particulier ici c'est la période de
reproduction est très réduite dans le
temps sur une fenêtre de deux à trois
semaines au printemps la rainette faux
grillon passe l'hiver en hibernation une
espèce qui peut congeler littéralement
elle gèle dur pour passer libéral à la
litière forestière puis au printemps
bacic parmi l'une des premières espèces
qui va se déplacer vers les diminuent
mais pour la reproduction
aussitôt le mât chante pour attirer les
femelles
[Musique]
au moment de l'accouplement il monte sur
son dos lasserre avec ses pattes une
boutique est justement capturé un couple
en plein ébat amoureux et enfin comme
par l'arrière
le mâle féconde les au fur et à mesure
que la femelle et relâche
sur une période d'environ deux mois les
uns féconde et se transforme en têtard
puis en grenouille est prête à quitter
les temps
pour cette métamorphose les rennais ont
besoin d'eau peu profonde ou elle ne
rencontre pas de prédateurs les fossés
et les marécages sont leurs lieux de
prédilection la rainette faux grillon
besoin d'un milieu aquatique qui sont
temporaires c'est à dire qu'il ya de
l'eau pendant seulement une partie de la
saison
le problème c'est qu'en montérégie ces
milieux humides ont été progressivement
grugés par la construction de projets
immobiliers
pour estimer la taille des populations
on ne peut évidemment pas compter les
grenouilles une à une l'équipe de
l'université laval utilise une toute
autre méthode
l'étudiant aurore paillard plonge les
rainettes dans une solution
anesthésiante environ une minute
une fois la grenouille endormie est la
seiche légèrement sa peau
elle fait une petite incision au niveau
de la nuque
[Musique]
avec une aiguille elle insère une puce
électronique sous la peau
[Musique]
un petit point de colle s'est raffermi
les cision dix minutes plus tard
l'intervention est terminée ça s'est
très bien passé notre monsieur s'est
réveillé c'est le même genre de
micropuces qu'on va insérer dans les
animaux domestiques le pour les chiens
ou les chats puis bref ce que ça fait
c'est une puce qui identifie un individu
avec un code unique une fois marqué les
rennais sont relâchés au même endroit où
ils ont été capturés
au cours des prochains jours l'équipe
répondra capturer des rainettes
à l'aide de scanners on pourra
déterminer quelle proportion des
grenouilles et muni d'une micropuce des
quelques statistiques permettront
d'estimer la taille réelle de la
population
les rennais thons capturés par l'ennemi
outillés pour connaître tout autre
destin
on va stimuler leur production puis
relâché leurs petits dans la nature pour
faire grossir les rangs de la population
regardez sur la glace
permettent de résister aux à la gamme a4
[Musique]
biodôme de montréal on a aménagé une
clinique de fertilité pour les
grenouilles
les mâles et les femelles sont pesées
puis mesuré
on injecte dans leur abdomen quand elle
d'hormones elle stimule l'ovulation chez
les femelles et la libération du sperme
chez les mâles
dans le passé l'équipe du biodôme a
tenté toutes sortes d'astuces pour
amener des rainette faux grillon à se
reproduire en captivité
une solution de dernier recours au cas
où l'espèce disparaîtrait on a essayé de
faire une limitation de la saison plus
froides ensuite une limitation de la
saison du dégel pied des variations de
température aussi des variations de
pluie de moments où c'est plus sec
toutes ces tentatives ont échoué
finalement on a fait appel à la
reproduction assistée si on veut avec
notre collaborateur de l'université
d'ottawa dr brandt pense trudeau qui
avec les injections hormonales on a
réussi à faire la reproduction en milieu
captifs
quelques heures après avoir reçu des
hormones des mâles se met à chanter
celui ci tente sa chance mais la femelle
le rejette
[Musique]
nous avons entendu tout l'après midi
pour les voir s'accoupler
c'est finalement le lendemain matin que
nous avons capté ces images
[Musique]
au total
2123 têtards sont nés en captivité au
biodôme
ils vont super bien ils sont super une
coureuse c'est ça qu'il faut à 2123 et
c'est tout à fait normal ça arrive
peut-être un plus haut tout en nature on
a quelques micros mortalité peut être un
ou deux par ci par là mais c'est rien de
dramatique
au début de l'été les efforts de toute
l'équipe atteint un point culminant
au parc national du mont-saint-bruno on
s'apprête à relâcher des grenouilles est
oui en captivité
la sépaq a aménagé quatre étant dans un
endroit peu fréquenté par les visiteurs
en principe dans les parcs nationaux
on laisse la nature
allez on n'intervient pas vraiment pour
changer la bido quoi que ce soit sauf
pour des espèces vulnérables des espèces
en péril
il a fallu cinq années de travail pour
convertir d'anciens fossé agricoles et
en faire des étangs parfait pour les
rainettes
mais le son parfait fanfare fait
même si le parc se trouve dans l'air de
répartition historique des rainettes
aucune n'a jamais été répertoriés ici
les babys grenouille on devoir coloniser
un nouveau territoire
[Musique]
avant de les relâcher aurore maillard
leur insère un marqueur c'est juste un
an un plan commun sous la boue qui est
visible à lampe uv ou à lyon il est
encore plus minuscule que la puce
employée pour les adultes donc on
encastre
immatériel
voiture de bien voir de ne pas couper
autre chose que leur peau
pac man comme cette fois c'est vrai que
c'est la différence aussi avec les
adultes c'est que on risquerait de
de leur faire en fait de dole mètres de
l'italien un petit peu partout parce que
la colle c'est très difficile dans ma
très juste un mini gouttes
[Musique]
après avoir repris leurs forces les
grenouilles est sont libérés dans les
étangs
on a mis tous ses efforts leur là
maintenant c'est à eux de jouer leur
rôle à voir s'ils vont le faire si on a
vraiment réussi à tour créé comme une
folle
tous espèrent entendre les rainette faux
grillon chanter au parc mont saint-bruno
le printemps prochain le succès reste
incertain
les taux de mortalité chez les bibis
grenouilles sont extrêmement élevés par
ailleurs un printemps particulièrement
chaud et sec pourrait anéantir la
population
même si on entend chanter le printemps
prochain la victoire rennes pointe
d'amertume
oui on ne peut être là la recette si on
veut pour recréer en laboratoire ou
artificiellement cette espèce là mais au
prix de tellement d'efforts puis nous
budget considérable aussi donc moi je
dis soutane mieux vaut se préserver en
amont
aux yeux des scientifiques protéger les
milieux humides qui trésors de
biodiversité qu'ils abritent serait
tellement plus simple
[Musique]